welcome
to this video a tactical
a tactical from spain
yeah queen's gambit
yeah okay well this is also an
interesting
line of the english i could have tried
g4 actually for once okay
but queen b3 already paid off in a way
because he
took on c3 without them
yeah letting me spend the tempo on a3
which normally
is really needed
okay let's gain some space
i'm not playing
okay maybe i should have played bishop
b2 first
it's not a big deal however
okay
i'm not playing d4 because i don't want
him to go knight e4
i want to keep my position as flexible
as possible
a flu and pawn structure
all right it's playing very quickly
huh
i didn't think the position is that easy
interesting d5
it's a very non-typical way to play it
i think he might have threatened deform
okay
i'm going to close this
okay if i take now
c takes he's got the knight on
c5
probably not a great idea
if i go to c2 he will take twice play e4
maybe
but okay taking on d4 is definitely not
the way to go
yeah i was thinking deform
very very
very very tough
position here
which of course he will continue to play
instantly because the most easiest thing
in the world
but
i'm totally unsure what what to make of
this
those
center pawns are not bad my bishop pair
not bad
the pawn on e4 and possibly e3 being
played
could be a bad thing to happen
let's see
can i go queen b3 maybe to
get out of the c file and maybe be ready
for e3 here
like e3 bishop f1
okay
not sure what this move is doing
okay
i definitely want a knight to control
this this e3 square maybe knight to e3
would be excellent
if he is not doing anything with this
pawn and i'm getting there this is
this is almost
almost a strategic win
that thing that thing for a moment
night i can also go to d6 here
this is this may be the the easiest
yeah come on let's do that
knight f5 and this queen really has no
really good squares it can go to g6
possibly
i can also play
this is actually actually very simple
and good
knight d6 and maybe i could have gone to
d6 even but if i get get queens traded
this is just terrible now
knight d6 comes
96 or
d5
okay let's let's jump in there
so i want to play c5 here
a4 bishop a3 c5 a rook f5 and rook f5
was possibly even better
or bishop to c6 it's also not bad yeah i
should do that actually
knight to d2 are you going to d2 or
i'm not sure
uh
i'm preparing c5 with this move
so c5 is he going to
yeah i can also do this and then c5
i also have bishop e5 sometime
not quite sure where he's going in the
first place
don't tell me rook h4 is a mate and come
on
no i can take e3
but oh
h4
yeah i can i can take him
oh
um
yeah what is the easiest here to take g3
probably
check
black resigns
yeah you just like played those kind of
insta moves all the time
i think up to now that's definitely okay
for black i mean why not he has a very
healthy position
he then took
and played this all instantly now d4
and now is the point where you need to
be very very
yeah
need to maybe uh think instead of just
push out moves because if i get after
this if i get to e3 with my knight this
game is over it's really over
strategically i've got
i've got the total i've got bishop pair
and i have those pushes and his majority
is is basically killed and he's doing
nothing against the thing
here
and here white wins it's just like that
it's not like
something
an advantage or whatever this is a
winning position and stockfish
for once agrees plus 2.2
it's just overwhelming
the center here the pawns control all
the
squares of the knights the knights are
dead this bishop is looking
on a on an old pawn
and white is just winning this however
he wants i mean
here here
96 immediately also wins but i wanted to
have the queens off to make it uh
simpler
and now we are
d6 d5 it's just a win
it's really uh just just to win like
that
um you absolutely
cannot trade down to this structure and
then not have something specific in mind
like e3 or whatever i don't think it
works because i'm just about in time but
just allowing the structure and getting
the knight to e3 is basically giving up
the game
but he decided on that um
almost instantly
yeah okay hope you liked it thanks for
watching